[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est dans
[Applaudissements]
ceux ci
puisqu'on a appelé à se dire à part
bonjour bonsoir chéri pas soit le seul
voilà shine on l'a tous en tête la
séquence qui m'a fait qui nous a tous
fait chavirer la séquence dans danse
avec les stars
[Musique]
sur la tête de ma mère puis je connais
moi ça alors on va faire qui sera la
meilleure shine bertrand shy'm eurois
sebha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si le campath
la deuxième c'est shine verdez
[Applaudissements]
il
ça suffit ça suffit
calme toi mais aussi du vernet si le
troisième alors lui franchement je
l'attends 15 ans on l'a jamais vu faire
des trucs comme ça y'a que sur des huit
dont tous par au poste il est comme ça
et je n'y arrivais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour moi c'est passionnant voyage
proclamer leur style c'est julien oui
non quelque chose à nos téléspectateurs
oui je vous pouvez voir été fait par des
professionnels ne le fait pas chez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]